today we welcome to the program Matthew
Connelly who's a Columbia history
professor and also author of the book
the declassification engine what history
reveals about America's Top Secrets a
really great having you on today I
appreciate your time great to be with
you David so you know we've been talking
about these recent classified documents
I guess it's it's fine to call them
scandals or news stories involving
Donald Trump and several hundred
documents and then Joe Biden and Mike
Pence reportedly with a small number of
documents that they didn't appear to be
deliberately keeping at their homes or
offices which is certainly a difference
to what we know so far about the Trump
story but there's sort of like a zooming
out that we can do more generally to
think about what sort of documents are
classified are we classifying the right
number of documents are there things
that are over classified and actually
reducing transparency so maybe to start
with what is the history of this concept
of these sorts of classification that
have been created
yeah well you might think you know that
this is something that governments do
you know you could think of it like
death and taxes right that uh government
officials would like to operate under
the cloak of secrecy but the fact is the
United States uh compared to other
countries anyway was really an outlier
you know for the first 150 years the U.S
was quite remarkable you know I think a
lot of people probably know we've never
had a Central Intelligence Agency uh we
we also unlike other countries we didn't
have what they used to call Black
Chambers where they would intercept and
decode Communications I mean almost
every other country the size of the U.S
uh had you know the means that actually
the motivation to track subversives they
would intercept their mail and so on in
the United States that was a felony so
you know both on the one hand it was a
matter of the US government not really
creating a lot of Secrets and then on
the other hand people had a very high
expectation as to their own personal
privacy so what we now take for granted
you know what some people call the
national secrecy complex you know what I
call the dark State it's really an
invention that lasts 80 years or so it
really only started after the second
World War
and when we talk about what types of
things are classified secret top secret
Etc all these different designations I
think the assumption is always that
these are extremely sensitive pieces of
information often related to probably
more foreign policy than domestic policy
I think that the assumption but there's
relatively mundane things that are also
designated in these ways oh sure you
know uh so it's interesting there's a
kind of you know dual dialogue going on
about secrecy where you know when you
bring out people who have their security
clearances and spent years in the
intelligence Community or what have you
yeah they'll tell you about all these
rules and how elaborate they are and how
careful people you know have to be but
the reality is you know if you actually
study this history and you look at what
people do every day they'll tell you
yeah you know I had to meet a colleague
for coffee and I classified that email
as top secret because because you know
at some point in the long email chain by
the time we finally figure out you know
which Starbucks you're going to I may
have said something about some program
you know that could be classified so
better safe than sorry you know and and
this is how you end up with what is now
a completely unmanageable situation you
know the state department generated some
2 billion email a year so just think of
the volume you know of these coffee you
know emails that end up being top secret
where for decades nobody's ever going to
see them unless somebody reviews that
stuff Page by Page to decide the rest of
us are allowed to read it so it seems
that the sort of most obvious concern
one would have about over classification
would be it reduces transparency there
are documents here that you know maybe
we don't post everything but at least
through foia requests should be
available if someone wanted them and you
reduce transparency if you over classify
is it that simple or what other concerns
are there with over classification
well you know for me as a historian I
care a lot you know about what a lot of
other people too would say is the court
of History you know because you know if
and it's true we have 18 different
intelligence agencies we have an 800
billion dollar defense department we
have this vast apparatus that's carrying
out covert operations you know targeted
assassinations you know wouldn't you
like to think that at some point you
know someone is going to be able to look
at all the evidence right to even if
it's only the court of History to hold
our leaders to account you know but I
could tell you that's just not going to
happen you know because even before the
era of electronic records you know this
age of Big Data the National Archives
could only keep about one to three
percent of the original documentary
record and if it's the case and it's
true we now have just to take another
example we have one intelligence agency
that's producing a petabyte of
classified data every single year if
those were paper records and they were
are lined up in file cabinets and file
folders it would Circle the equator and
even the government says it would take 2
million archivists just to go through
that to decide what the rest of us are
allowed to know so yeah that's important
I think it matters because if you think
you know history matters and ultimately
you know holding our leaders to account
that matters quite a lot but I'll tell
you the other reason it matters and this
is also not trivial when they can't
decide what's actually secret they can't
protect the stuff that really could kill
people and we've just seen one after
another you know and these really are
scandals like NSA CIA hacking tools you
know getting stolen we've seen you know
the Chinese government apparently taking
tens of millions of personnel records
with which they could use to Blackmail
people who do have top secret security
clearances right so that too is a real
danger and it's a it's a danger here and
now I mentioned the Trump Biden Pence
controversies we could include in that
Hillary Clinton in in a sense I mean it
was looked at by the FBI it related more
to an email server uh how do you assess
these types of controversies in terms of
how they compare to one another and kind
of the big picture significance as to
how common more generally it is I mean I
I said the other day I wouldn't be
shocked if secretaries of state had a
few documents lying around then it's
just not a high priority to look I I
just don't know
yeah and you
I actually do
you know whether it's about you know
Hillary Clinton or email or you know
Biden Pence Trump Etc et cetera et
cetera maybe I'll learn even more names
soon enough I also go back to the way in
which storing the George W Bush
Administration they used to write their
email using Republican National
Committee email servers right what all
these things have in common is that
these are public officials doing the
people's business and they treat the
record of those actions their decisions
as if it were their private property
where they have no obligation to share
that information with the National
Archives why does that matter because
you know it's our history you know
wouldn't we like to think you know that
as Citizens you know we could file
freedom information act requests right
maybe we'd like to know what the George
W Bush Administration is doing maybe
we'd like to know what secretary Clinton
was doing you know but if they'd gotten
away with it and to be honest to a large
extent they did yeah you know a lot of
those records would never be recoverable
and none of us would ever have the
ability to to see them and so you know
that's why I say like uh as an historian
I take the longer view you know and I'm
sorry to say but you know even if some
of these cases you know the most
egregious of all of course is Donald
Trump even if some of these cases are
worse than others I think we've all of
us got to wake up and see you know that
uh whether it's Democrats doing it or
Republicans to do it we we have to
recognize that this is something all of
us should care about when it comes to
the Trump thing like as an example it's
hard to imagine that the things he would
want to have down at his house are email
chains about which Starbucks people are
meeting at but without something more
more tangible maybe it's not totally
clear like what what kinds of things
could they be what does the what are the
sorts of categories of things that he
might have down there that one would
want to have yeah well you know we know
apparently you know that some of these
documents uh related to uh president
macron France
um you know I don't know but I I think
uh it's typically the case that you know
presidents before they have
international meetings they'll get
briefing books right uh we know like
from what Edward Snowden revealed uh
that the NSA you know did try to Target
you know foreign heads of state some of
them allies right that they intercepted
their Communications it's entirely
possible you know that in those records
we have you know examples of how it is
the NSA intercepted Communications maybe
some of them are incriminating and
that's why we're going to talk about
them endlessly because there's something
intrinsically fascinating about
something that's secret and
psychologists who study this like you
could take random pieces of paper you
stamp them top secret and in controlled
experiments people always think that
those are the pieces of paper that are
more important those are the things they
have to pay attention to you know so yes
it could be a big deal and you know the
fact that those documents were unsecured
and could have been stolen I mean we
know that there were foreign operatives
who are active you know trying to
penetrate Mar-A-Lago there was one guy
you know I think he was a Chinese
National who went in with many uh you
know USB sticks right you don't usually
take like eight or ten USB sticks to the
pool
so yes we
sorry about that but again I think it's
part of a much bigger story
um the protocol around a lot of these
documents at least as far as members of
the House and Senate have said is
depending on their classification there
would be particular rooms where the
documents are kept where when you go in
you have to leave your phone outside you
know the idea is prevent anybody from
even photographing the documents you're
not allowed to take notes you basically
look at it and I guess the idea is
you're sort of committing to memory
whatever about it is relevant or
interesting or you want to look into is
that a process that makes sense at this
point in time given the sort of digital
age that we're in yeah well you know
those are the rules that the executive
branch imposes on the legislative branch
and Congress has to abide by them or
they don't get to see anything right uh
but on the other hand you know it's a
well-known fact you know that when for
example you know say staffers the
National Security Council let's say they
go into a meeting you know to decide
what's the U.S going to do if China
tries to take Taiwan you know they may
be handling lots of classified records
right and they know that they have to be
careful of those records but when they
take notes do you think that they always
classify them even if they're talking
about the same information it's a
well-known fact that oftentimes those
notes go home with them and sometimes
when they leave you know the National
Security Council those notes end up in
their homes right and staying there one
reason for that you know of course like
people want to do work sometimes people
work long hours they want to be able to
work at home but another reason is a lot
of people want to go on write their
Memoirs right and and look like when you
see all of the books that come out right
both during but especially after
administrations end when you know who
those people are and how it is that they
go around to Publishers and they get
their big advances is it always because
they are so gifted right at telling a
good story no it's typically because
they say you know at least imply that
they are going to reveal these secrets
right these things that they knew during
their time in the Trump White House so
in that way they are monetizing you know
information that's supposed to belong to
all of us so to me again that is really
to me even more so than say National
Security that's the bigger story here on
the issue of the books you know you will
often read articles that say well a
former Secretary of State wrote a book
and the Pentagon looked at the book to
evaluate whether there was anything
being revealed that but you you sort of
know the drill what about that process
in terms of is is someone at the
Pentagon really so involved that they
would say this name you mentioned on
page 120 you need to change that and say
it's a source you can't name or like at
what level are they presiding over the
books that are published they will deny
it but there are different rules for
different people right so if you're Mike
Pompeo right and you have amazing things
to say you know about the CIA right and
how awesome it is and how they protect
our people all the time in ways they
can't quite reveal then you're going to
get one kind of reading and you're going
to get different kinds of redactions or
maybe none at all right if you're
another kind of person right like even
John Bolton say and let's say like when
you conclude your time in the Trump
White House and you want to tell all and
you want to say really critical things
you know about the president the former
president now you know then you're going
to get a very different reading they're
going to give you a much harder time
it's even harder you know for people who
do not have the kind of name recognition
can't hire the kind of lawyers you know
that somebody like Bolton can and
instead like have to wait sometime
months sometimes years right to get that
reading and God forbid this is somebody
who really wants to tell you what's
really happening you know whether it's
at the NSA or the CIA those people go
through a real ordeal right and if they
make mistakes they get prosecuted yeah
that seems to be an area where the over
classification I mean people writing
their Memoirs is not of the utmost
importance when we think about the grand
scheme of things but it seems that
that's directly affected by this over
classification that you're talking about
where many many government hours end up
going into reviewing the books and
redacting them because of the very
overclassification that is in place
yeah I mean they do uh and they've been
doing it for for decades now I mean
there are some civil liberties lawyers
who are trying to challenge this process
because what they would point out is
like for example after the end of the
Trump Administration wouldn't we like to
know everything we possibly can about
what happened you know in those years
like wouldn't we like to know as much as
we can about January 6th well if it's
the case that currently serving
government officials are the ones to
decide what we're allowed to know then
basically that information is being
censored
um and so we're only going to know what
the government allows us to know all in
the name of National Security
hey last thing I I know that your
expertise is in history not Grammar but
I heard you say during this interview
and historian and then you also said a
historian this is actually my audience
writes in about this it is either
correct in your mind
I that's did I really say a historian I
thought well maybe I misheard it
me too
yeah I don't know if there's a rule yeah
it's not really clear to me it's just my
Quirk well we'll look into it we'll look
into it all right Matthew Connolly
Columbia history Professor we're linking
to his book of the declassification
engine what history reveals about
America's Top Secrets really appreciate
your time and insights today
thank you David